[Música]
i
en qué piensan los financieros
si yo les digo con esta taza mejor no
nos metemos porque no nos apalancamos un
poquito en que hablo hablo en mi línea
habló el extranjero no hablo en finanzas
y donde encontramos las finanzas las
finanzas las encontramos si pensamos en
una gran biblioteca acerca de la física
acerca de la química más allá de la
biología en la metafísica no ahí no
están las finanzas aunque algún
alquimista ahí en finanzas las
encontramos jugando en en el arenero de
una plaza donde juegan las ciencias
económicas ahí mientras hace dibujitos
en ese arenero de esa plaza del barrio
de las ciencias sociales de la ciudad de
la ciencia y este tipo de analogías hace
que la gente me mire raro así como está
pero bueno salvando estos pensemos con
quién juegan las finanzas juegan con sus
hermanitas sus hermanitas de la ciencia
de la administración
juegan con recursos humanos juegan con
marketing y todas las sentimos geniales
y colores y las finanzas que hacen hacen
números si con un palitos y entonces
están cerca de unas primas vieron cómo
son los primos son parecidos a nosotros
pero se crearon en otra casa entonces
quiénes son sus primas contabilidad y
economía estas dos están ahí cerquita
mientras contabilidad junta hojitas del
plato no y las ordena economía mira para
todos lados
y entonces qué piensas finanzas finanzas
va pensando en el futuro pero volvamos a
las primas contabilidad tiene una
personalidad ordenada contabilidad
ordena como juntaba hojitas del plátano
cuando era chica ahora junto a papeles
pero junto a todo mira el pasado
contabilidad siempre va a mirar el
pasado es documental necesita la
documentación punta demasiado junta las
cartas de los novios que ya no las
quiere todo junto a contabilidad y
economía y economía empieza a pensar
pero es de esas personas que uno va con
una pelota pinchada y le dicen mira si
la fifa no cambia las reglas siga con
mejor no hacia algo este fútbol no se
puede jugar más y no dice si tiene razón
pero se queda con la pelota pinchada
entonces finanzas piensa en el futuro
pero a su vez piensa en determinados
tips y ahí vamos a ver
primero piensa en términos relativos las
finanzas siempre piensan en tasas nadie
de finanzas va a pensar gane un millón
le va a decir gane el 30 por ciento es
decir la relación entre lo que puse y lo
que obtuve si no es lo mismo obtener un
millón invirtiendo millón que un un
millón invirtiendo 100 visuales entonces
cuando hablemos de finanzas o con
alguien de finanzas nos va a hablar en
términos relativos
mi director de tesis dice que las tesis
son repetitivas y entonces volvemos
volvemos al futuro que miran del futuro
de las finanzas el futuro da origen a
las finanzas el futuro permite que dos
personas se pongan de acuerdo en comprar
y vender algo porque del futuro piensan
diferente entonces creen primero que los
dos van a ganar y a veces no ganan datos
y a veces pierden los dos y generalmente
gana uno y pierde el otro pero es el
futuro lo que le permite a las finanzas
funcionar
y en el futuro están los vientos
porque tenemos miedos las finanzas trata
de pensar como piensan los directores
del cine como hace un director de cine
para darnos miedo nos da más información
a nosotros como espectadores que el
protagonista si pone el monstruo pone la
puerta y pone el protagonista y lo hace
abrir la puerta y nosotros decimos no no
abras la puerta
bueno las finanzas tratamos de entender
de dónde vienen los miedos y los miedos
vienen de los riesgos si de la
posibilidad que algo no se dé tal cual
lo planificamos en esos riesgos vamos a
tener atado los rendimientos
el tema es que cada persona asume una
postura ante el riesgo hay personas que
son adversas al riesgo hay personas que
son neutrales que no les importa hay
personas que les gusta los deportes
extremos y los riesgos financieros
entonces que le va a pedir las finanzas
a los riesgos rendimientos atado a un
gran rendimiento va a haber un gran
riesgo siempre es decir acá no está el
pie si le proponen las famosas estafa de
las mandalas
gana mucha plata poniendo poca hay un
gran riesgo figura en wikipedia
búsquenlo el esquema post y es una
estafa del año 30 si entonces no se
crean que es gratis alguien pierde
ahora las finanzas no siempre jugamos al
ataque no siempre somos el barcelona con
todo a veces hay que pensar cómo hacemos
para tomar decisiones si van las cosas
complicadas en finanzas esos son
decisiones de cobertura siempre que
tomamos decisiones también hacemos la
cobertura por eso es esta palabra rara
apalancamiento que lo nombré apalancar
es pedir plata a terceros no es nada más
que eso es préstamo que sucede que
cuando pedimos plata a terceros nuestro
negocio se hace más grande y entonces el
resultado se va para arriba con una
condición que la tasa a la que pedimos
sea más chica que el rendimiento que
tenemos si pedimos préstamos caros
estamos fritos no nos apalancamos nada
costos un dios si vemos ahí el
hundimiento de medusa que esté en el
louvre vemos que qué le pasó a la gente
del naufragio no está pensando en el
barco el barco ya fue si ustedes hacen
un emprendimiento y tienen un terreno
familiar que lo compró el abuelo hace 30
años y generalmente no hay ningún
candidato para comprarlo por más que de
inmobiliaria de otra cosa nadie ese
costo no lo tenemos en cuenta es hundido
ya está no lo vamos a recuperar no
podemos armar un recupero de los errores
del pasado
finanzas deja los costos del pasado en
el fondo del mar
cuando tomamos muchas decisiones
respecto de muchos escenarios posibles
ya no tenemos una decisión financiera lo
que tenemos es una estrategia financiera
ahí podemos incluir la cobertura es
decir las finanzas no pueden parar una
tormenta pero si claramente decirnos
cómo cuándo y de qué manera nos
compramos un paraguas
acá me detengo un ratito
dicen que gabriel garcía márquez cuando
terminó de editar su libro cien años de
soledad quemó los manuscritos
maestro le pregunta por qué como los
manuscritos no quería que me encontraran
sabiendo como yo armé esto pero no en el
sentido de secretos sino que era como
encontrarme en el patio de mi casa decía
en paños menores es dirigir y daba
vergüenza bueno mucha gente y muchas
empresas de genera vergüenza hablar de
su flujo de fondos si no tenemos que ser
de vergüenza no nos sentamos expuestos
armemos cuánto entre cuánto sale de
nuestra familia de nuestra empresa de
nuestra organización lo podemos hacer y
nos da muchísima información del futuro
siempre los flujos de fondos son del
futuro ahora
vamos a tratar de responder la pregunta
en qué piensa la financiera los
financieros piensan en todo esto en
muchas cosas más todos juntos y allí sí
hay una patita de la dificultad que
todos sentimos con las finanzas el
problema es que los que están muy
acostumbrados a esto piensa en todo
junto y muy rápido y los que no estamos
tan acostumbrados tenemos que separar
cada decisión financiera en partes y
empezar a evaluarla de la de los riesgos
de la de los rendimientos del
apalancamiento y eso ya se hace mucho
más simple de tomar
para qué quiero hecho saber finanzas un
alumno de la facultad un día me vino con
un caso de una
cobro de un cobro bastante oneroso de
intereses un hermano y me dice prof esto
nueves como lo habíamos visto lo mire y
tenía razón fue protestó se peleó con
los abogados y consiguió que le bajan al
lado para eso sirve las finanzas
para tratar de defendernos para que no
tengan más información los demás que
nosotros nos tenemos que meter
ya seamos una persona en su hogar que
dice cuánto 24 salario una empresa pyme
que no sabe cuánto cobre cuánto paga un
gran inversor que trata de ir a la bolsa
oa las nuevas corrientes que hay en
financiera todos podemos hacer finanzas
hay finanzas para no financieros
finanzas para emprendedores finanzas
para la bolsa hay miles de finales
entonces si estás en tu casa y haces
cuenta si estás en tu empresa y también
ves cuanto entré y sales o si sos un
estudiante que te llevas bien con los
números pero no te gustan otras cosas
pero te llevas bien con las empresas
entonces yo creo que puedes pensar que
es posible pasarse a finanzas
[Música]
ah
y